from everyone to the webinar SEO for
video get more clicks views and
subscribers does anybody learn
I'm your host Stewart Creek marketing
manager here at simply learned and your
presenter today is a thought leader in
digital marketing Matt Bailey more about
him in a moment
but first you notes on how to
participate webinar and as you can see
you have marketing managers with us
today a number of people in other
categories most of you are eager to
learn about the use of video in digital
marketing and that's what we're here for
so it's now my great pleasure to
introduce Matt Bailey is a digital
marketing faculty member it's simply
learned that is the founder and
president of site logic marketing he's
also digital marketing instructor for
the Direct Marketing Association in New
York City an instructor for the OEM CP
online marketing certified professional
program it's also the author of internet
marketing an hour a day fired to be loud
teach an old dog new tricks welcome Matt
I'm glad to hear everyone is interested
to learn about SEO for video I started
in search engine optimization in about
the mid 90s and that's where I got my
start in digital marketing and so it's
just been a fascinating evolution with
YouTube because what we've been trying
to do an optimization in Google is
optimize websites for rankings now with
YouTube it's very similar it still
belongs to Google but it's an amazing
change from optimizing websites to
optimizing individual videos as well as
your channel YouTube's got over a
billion users it makes up about a third
of the Internet and so it's an amazing
opportunity to reach so many different
people in so many different languages
across the world and so it's very
important to employ search engine
optimization
techniques or video as well now here's
what is very similar about search engine
optimization for video number one it is
still dependent upon keywords just like
you're optimizing your website so the
more you understand keywords what people
are searching for and the content they
want to see the better you'll be able to
employ that in your video now that goes
into your content planning if you know
what people want to see it'll help you
develop content for them but also to
optimize your existing content will also
look at popularity metrics and how you
can use those to optimize your videos
it's the same thing
we utilize metrics and analytics to
optimize our pages based on the feedback
of who's clicking what they see and what
they do similarly when we look at the
snippet of information on Google when
people search there's a title a headline
the URL and a little description of a
page in video we have an image and that
changes everything
so those are the things we're going to
look at as we go through today's webinar
like I said it starts with keyword
research I want to go back to my keyword
research that I've done if I've done a
search engine optimization for my
website and I want to know what are
people searching for what problems are
they trying to solve right now if you go
to Google and you type in how to which
is an attempt to solve a problem or find
information what you're going to see are
videos from YouTube in the Google
results so one of the biggest uses of
YouTube is people going there to find
out how to do something so figure out
what problem they need to solve that's
related to your business what kind of
content is related to your business and
find out what words people use you can
also go to YouTube and utilize some of
those words to search and see who else
shows up what's their content about what
channels are there how many videos do
they have but also look at their
personality YouTube is a largely
personality driven media
whereas on your website it's mainly text
and so on the video people can hear
watch and you've got all of that
additional input to how you answer a
question as opposed to just text so in
your keyword research start organizing
key words I just looked at something
here about dog training just to see what
would show up and there's a lot of
information as far as what people want
people want to control undesirable
behavior in their dogs they want to
produce desirable behaviors like stop
barking but also how to do tricks and so
training keywords and also we see a
distinct difference doing puppies and
dogs locations how to information
housebreaking is a big keyword term and
so I want to look at all the keywords
that are available in this context and
then I want to start develop content
themes now very similar on a website we
would develop content themes and our
hierarchy and create those however on
video
these will develop into categories that
we'll be publishing and your videos
would be under a category heading so we
want to develop content themes of
stopping undesirable behaviors creating
desirable behaviors like obedience
training tricks but then also how to
lots of how-to content now this is where
in keywords we utilize the longtail
hopefully you you've seen some simply
learned content in the SEO sections
about longtail of keywords and what the
long tail is are those extended searches
where people utilize four to five or six
word phrases to really describe a
problem or information that they want to
see the short tail are the the one to
two word popular terms that get hundreds
or hundreds of thousands of searches
every month what we're looking at
especially in YouTube are very specific
phrase
as words problems descriptions that
people make that is a lot of what does
well on YouTube and the better you
describe your video the more visibility
it will have so then take those keywords
and utilize those to script your video
now a lot of times I see some people
that are able to you know a lot of
YouTube personalities they've got almost
a show where they don't script a lot but
the first five seconds are typically
scripted now if you're doing this from a
business standpoint less of a
personality standpoint you've got to
answer people's questions and the more
you answer their questions the more you
keep their engagement stay focused on
what you are doing in the information
you are presenting and utilize keywords
I'm a big fan of writing a script and
staying on a script you can utilize this
through some very inexpensive hardware
to take videos have teleprompters
anything that will help you stay on a
script and the advantage of this if your
script is written and in a document you
can utilize that later when you upload
your video you can upload your script as
well for subtitles in that way we're
getting our keywords into the video
we're also getting our keywords into the
script function now when scripting your
video I tell people it's a short five
step process of a script the first is
introduce yourself tell people who you
are what you're doing who what business
you represent and then number two very
quickly get to what you're going to do
and then number three do it
demonstrate it show it show how it's
done now at the conclusion at the end of
your video here's what I did you restate
what you did in number two you told
people what you're going to do you did
it and now you tell them what you did
you wrap it up in a conclusion then you
have a call to action now you do this
and this is where you ask people to
click on subscribe to leave a comment
you click on the link and go to a
landing page to go to your website and
there are a lot of tools within the
videos that you can utilize to move
people along through a progression to
get to your site or a landing page so
that's the basic outline introduce
yourself tell them what you're gonna do
do it tell them what you just did and
now tell them what to do so now let's
optimize our videos for the YouTube
search algorithm the first thing is to
write attractive titles titles are one
of the first things that people see and
they judge whether or not they will
click on the video based on the title
the title is also the primary content
that the search engine will view now
remember YouTube is a search engine just
the same way that Google is a search
engine YouTube relies on text-based
content in order to determine which
videos are more important than others
that's just one of the factors and so
the text that you use in your titles
descriptions and all those things
utilizing keywords helps to increase the
relevance so describe your content in
the title use a couple of keywords but
also make some excitement how to's are
great title starters because they show
people what they will be able to do
utilize benefits ask questions but keep
it in about 60 characters or less
that way your entire title will be
visible to the searcher on both a mobile
and desktop device so you don't have
much space but you've got to utilize the
space by using keywords and making it
exciting I'm going to show you a number
of methods of writing titles now first
is what I call the clickbait title now
the clickbait it's a sensationalized
title I'm sure we've all seen these in
and they utilize a lot of all caps
you'll notice on the one example on the
right it's the entire title is in caps
and in the one on the left a couple
the words are in all caps it's to get
your attention it's almost like yelling
the title now sometimes these titles are
also misspelled on purpose because that
gets your attention they're very
aggressive in presenting the key word
the title and what's going on
but the clickbait creates a title that
you can't help but want to click on
that's the idea of it and sometimes they
say things that are so outrageous makes
you click on the video just to see if
it's true
that's the clickbait title now as I said
before the how to title this is a
problem and a solution these are very
popular in the search results and so
utilizing how to's can increase your
visibility in Google not just in YouTube
this is largely instructional content as
you can see here it's how to make the
perfect pizza how to do a home
renovation you're showing people what
they can do utilizing a lot of the words
that they use in searches how-to is a
very popular search now related to the
how-to is the problem and solution but
without saying how to it addresses a
question it expands it but without the
how-to it develops more keywords so in
this example yoga poses for beginners
where to start utilizing keywords
beginners where to start yoga poses but
without the how-to so it's still a
question and answer a problem-solution
format also on the left what is an IDE
great way because that is probably
utilizing search keywords that people
are searching for and just restating
from the search results right into the
page into the video title so look at the
questions that people were asking and
utilize those now there's also a benefit
just to stating the facts of what it is
it's to the point no hype very short
you're not building any empathy or any
emotion you're just explaining what the
video is all about this can be very
effective and
realize not all of these titles are
appropriate for all business types or
for all types of channels a lot of this
depends on your personality
and the business you have and how you
are presenting information so I'm
showing you a wide variety but it's up
to you to figure out what's going to be
the best for your business now one thing
that really works well are lists people
are fascinated by lists and it really
sets the stage for the content that's
going to follow for example 15 shortcuts
you aren't using four levels of Raman it
shows people what's going to happen when
they watch the video it sets an
expectation clear expectation it tells
them that the content is going to be
very condensed and presented in an
organized format and that appeals to
people now the next one is what I like
to call the secret sauce and this is
where the video where the video producer
is going to teach you something that you
don't know and only they do it's very
similar to clickbait they usually hype
it as a mystery or a little known
information and we're going to show you
how to do it so it's it's similar to the
clickbait it's almost a combination of
the clickbait and the how to with a
problem-solution
it's just that they're the only ones
that know this solution and they're
going to share it with you so that's the
secret sauce and again
these are all very effective in
different ways now the last one
certainly not in any realm this is just
from my observation of YouTube and how
people are writing these things it's the
combination it's you can combine all of
those title types and make your own six
woodworking tips and tricks for
beginners Home Organization tips and
hacks hacks are a great word people love
that this will take minutes and save
your dog's life you can develop this for
your own style your own personality the
key is figuring out what attracts the
audience or the content that you use and
that you promote what does your audience
light
and your analytics will show you
click-through rates
watch rates and you can try different
title types but the combo is where you
create your own mix pulling from the
different styles that people have now
the next text area is the description
you looked at the title now the
description where the title had about 60
characters the description has a
thousand characters however only 100
characters or less are visible in the
YouTube results or in the YouTube
suggested videos window and so within
100 characters you need to be able to
present a clear idea or a clear summary
of what the video is about you can
utilize promotional language you can
explain a little bit more and in order
to see the rest of the description
people have to click on show more now
when people click on that this is just a
basic text field and so if you just
write paragraphs of content no one's
going to look at that you need to break
up that content utilize the bold text
line breaks capitalize and create a call
to action you can put links in here so
again it's it's a just a dense text
field you don't have a lot of markup
capability in here and so utilize a lot
of these whatever is available to you to
break apart the text to make it very
easily seen and scanned people aren't
going to read a whole paragraph they're
not going to read sentences so be brief
break it up
utilize links in this section to take
people to your landing pages on your
site especially if you're promoting your
company or products or something like
that
next is what before you upload your file
to YouTube optimize the file name this
is one of those little things that
people forget to do but remember YouTube
is a text-based search engine just like
Google and so your file name instead of
you know the technical
or the format that you may have within
your company I have an example here you
know video 0:08 final change it to
describe what's going to happen in the
video so if I'm teaching a jog how to
play fetch or dog training I'm going to
use those words change the name or the
file name before you upload it now when
you upload a file you also have an
opportunity to add tags this is a very
minor feature it was used early in
YouTube it's not always seen by viewers
but it is used to classify the content
and so if I'm using dog training videos
I'm going to utilize dog training tags
like training obedience training dogs
puppies I'm explaining what's in the
video now even though this is a minor
feature and it's not always shown to the
viewer you want to avoid using tags that
aren't relevant to the video this is one
area where people have seen that their
video or their channel has been
penalized by utilizing tags or keywords
that aren't relevant or associated to
the content in the video so avoid doing
that now sometimes you may decide to the
video on your own website instead of in
YouTube and Google will still crawl your
website and they can crawl your video
and so you don't always have to rely on
your YouTube video to get into the
rankings videos that are embedded in
your website have just as much
opportunity to be in the Google rankings
as YouTube videos it's up to you to
decide how you are going to go about
doing that if you are going to utilize
self-hosting and curating videos on your
own website instead of video sites then
I recommend that you use schema or
markup language here and the the
resource for this is at schema.org
so if you are embedding your video what
schema.org is it will present the markup
instructions that will work for every
search engine crawler every search
engine and it will present to them the
information about that video in an
accepted format across all search
engines and so you'll you'll use a
headline an h1 a headline - which is a
subheading you'll tell it the name of
the video duration of the video you can
also connect it to your own thumbnail
image of the video and you're showing
that in the schema markup of where the
search engine can get all this
information and associate it together
again you want to name the file type and
description but this enables you to
utilize your own website as a video
hosting location rather than using
YouTube or Vimeo or others and this is
just mainly based on your choice
there are advantage advantages and
disadvantages to this the next is
utilizing the subtitles and closed
captioning again the more text you add
to your videos the more it enhances the
ability for search engines to see the
text and use that in the ranking
algorithm now I'm going to use my
channel here as an example and show you
that when you are in your YouTube studio
this is where you can add your
transcriptions and you can see here in
the navigation on the left there is a
transcription tab for a specific video
you can choose the video and it will
show you any transcriptions that are
already created if you've had some
videos on YouTube for a while you may
already have a transcription that has
been made through YouTube's
text-to-speech engine or speech to text
engine and they've created an automated
closed caption or transcription you can
also add your own when you upload it or
edit what's there already
so when you choose the video to make the
transcription this is what will show the
video will show and then you have
options here on the side you have
options to upload the file or transcribe
or and auto sync or create new subtitles
and closed captioning those are your
choices and so we're going to choose the
transcribe and auto-sync
and this is what happens it will show
you timestamps throughout the video and
for about every sentence where that
appears in the video so I can see here
my first five seconds in this video and
I can see the sentence that is there
within the first five seconds of the
video
I can add a transcription I can edit
what's there I can also edit the timings
for each sentence as it goes along with
the video this is a great way of adding
the text into the video which enhances
your ability to rank now as you upload
your videos this this part isn't always
visible unless you're in the studio your
basic video uploader doesn't ask you a
lot of additional information
aside from uploading the video when you
get into your YouTube studio then you
can choose the video and add more
information you can add add or edit the
title the description but then it will
ask you additional information such as
where does this play in the organization
how do you group your videos by theme
and content this is where your keyword
research comes in and you can develop
categories for your videos
so on the right hand side of my studio I
can choose my playlists and create a
playlist and we'll see cards and end
screens I'll add those things and at the
bottom left you can see tags and here's
where you add the tags or thumbnails and
we'll get to a lot of that later you can
choose a thumbnail that YouTube creates
or you can create your own
in adding playlists there's an advantage
to this if you add videos you create a
playlist and add videos to that playlist
this is a great organization technique
for your channel but it also increases
your visibility because once one of your
videos is done playing it will
automatically go to the next video in
the playlist and this is how you can
increase your visibility and increase
the amount of place is by associating
these videos and so if someone is
watching it it goes right to the next
video in the playlist this also lets
YouTube know by the algorithm that
people are just going through each video
in your channel and in that playlist
it helps YouTube know what content
people are interested in so here is an
example of a playlist being used and
this is a video of music for dogs to
help dogs relax but look at what is up
next in the upper right and that is part
to another video from the same channel
because they've got that in the playlist
now there is a I've gone over the
text-based areas are very similar to
search engine optimization for your
regular website these are all the things
that you can do to enhance the ranking
ability of your video now YouTube though
has a very different layer on
optimization that Google does not and
that's popularity by popularity what I
mean is that most the UV popular
channels and creators people who already
have millions of followers on YouTube
they're favored over other content and
what that means is people that are
already popular or going to get more
popular and sometimes sensationalized
content overrules quality factual and
authoritative content
it's what's popular is
what's popular now what's what's true or
factual and so there is a popularity
algorithm and what this is called is the
power law algorithm the power law means
that what's popular will continue to be
popular because that will be what
YouTube
constantly recommends if you just go to
youtube if you have an account on
YouTube you'll notice when you open it
up
YouTube has kind of figured out what you
like but it will also suggest popular
channels popular related content of
popular people it's because they know
that because these people are already
popular if they suggest it to you
chances are you will watch that as well
but here's the implications of this 80%
of YouTube views are generated by just
11% of YouTube creators that's about
500,000 creators are responsible for 80%
of the views the next million-and-a-half
creators only get 11% of the views and
then the next 2.6 million creators only
get 8% of the views
that's power law power law is the 80/20
that the minority of producers gets the
majority of views a normal distribution
is more focused based on demand and
based on what people like and you see
that the distribution go further down
and it actually involves more people our
law focuses on your high highly popular
creators and continues to recommend and
push and favor them rather than other
content at this point I'm gonna hand it
over to Stuart again for our next poll
Thank You Matt before Matt moves on to
actionable advice I'd like to check in
with you all here is a poll question how
do you use SEO in your work I'll give
you a couple of moments to answer the
question couple minutes
see the poll results coming and it's
interesting not as many of you are
currently using it in video content I
guess that's why you're here for this
webinar content marketing obviously is a
main reason we'll share the poll results
20 seconds from now your answers in
please Oh content marketing certainly
it's the most popular way to use SEO
content and website conversion are also
just and I will move on turn it back
over to Matt the next segment you
Stewart feedback to know as we get into
the rest of the content here so what can
you do with this power law distribution
it seems like everything's stacked
against you if you're a new creator or a
smaller Channel and unfortunately that's
true it is stacked against you but there
are things you can do to grow your
popularity and to increase your metrics
in order to take advantage of some of
the aspects of the YouTube algorithm the
first thing that you can do is market
your content outside of YouTube that
means go directly to your audience now
you can do that by putting videos on
your own website
and hosting them there rather than in
YouTube or Vimeo or even if you are
using YouTube and Vimeo going to your
audience through email other forms of
marketing and driving people to a
landing page that utilizes those videos
prompt your audience to subscribe but
then also more than that prompt them
from your YouTube channel to go to your
website and subscribe tell them that
your email list is where the exclusive
content and exclusive offers are not
just on your YouTube so move them from
becoming a Youtube subscriber to an
email subscriber and that way you can
grow your list continue to link your
videos in other areas linked in social
areas linked from your website ask
people to share your videos or embed
them but don't just focus on YouTube
focus on utilizing links utilizing your
your videos to build
links to your website and marketing to
people so that they can see your content
outside of YouTube creates additional
links creates additional demand bringing
people to YouTube and that can help
build your popularity so that's the
thing what is it that builds popularity
on YouTube let's look at some very
specific things where the popularity
algorithm uses for evaluation number one
as you can imagine it is the
click-through rate that is based on how
many times your video appears on the
screen in search results and recommended
videos how many times is it clicked
based on the impression and so that is a
high high metric on youtubes algorithm
is the click-through rate of impressions
to clicks so that makes your entry there
your title your thumbnail your
description now you have to make it
clickable you have to make people want
to click it and give them a reason to
click it because that will build your
popularity the second factor is watch
time and retention so if you have a 5
minute video and you are getting people
to watch half of the video that will
count against you what YouTube watches
is how long do people watch your video
and at what point do the majority of
viewers drop off you lose 60 to 70
percent of your viewers after 2 minutes
after 4 minutes or after the first 30
seconds if there is a drop off rate that
is significant and it is early in the
video then that will negatively affect
your visibility and popularity retention
is how long you keep the majority of
people on your video all the way through
to the end those are two major factors
in popularity is how long you engage
people on your video and how long you
keep them all the way through to the end
that after the video how many people
click the subscribe button how many
people leave a comment or rate the video
that shows that they are engaged and so
these factor into popularity as well
this is why you should always end your
video with asking people to take action
take an action like subscribe click add
to your favorites anything like that
leave a comment that helps show that
people are engaged with your channel and
interested in your content so the whole
thing is about getting people not just
to click your video but to click
subscribe to click the like button and
so how do we get that click as we can
see the click-through rate is one of the
major factors well the only thing that
people can see is the thumbnail image
the title of your video short
description a channel name how many
views and the age of the video those are
the only areas where people can that's
the only information they have to decide
to make the click so what do people
expect well that's the key we need to
know our audience we need to know what
they want and what appeals to them and
we went through some of the titles but
as you can see here there is a distinct
difference as to how do people present
their videos you can take a very
professional approach especially as a
business that might be what people
expect and so understanding your
audience and how they view the
information they're going to receive and
how they view you as the provider is
going to be critical here as an example
let's look at non business videos
YouTube is full of personalities of
gamers of gaming walkthroughs and other
types of entertainment if you have
children who watch YouTube you have seen
a lot of these things now if you're a
business you probably won't use
thumbnails that look like this
this is all about understanding who your
audience is and what appeals to them so
let's look at thumbnail images because
this could make or break your business
and how you're presenting yourself
number one I call it the professional
thumbnail it's a very clear presentation
it is a sans-serif font when you're
developing titles and headlines
sans-serif fonts work extremely well
both of these I believe are using Arial
as the font and you'll notice there's
not a lot of hype it's very clear and
the title is on the thumbnail and it's a
very professional look to it if you're a
business and you're presenting
professional information chances are
this is what you've got to go with and
there's a number of ways to do it so you
can create your own business look and
feel by developing a clean professional
look to your videos now if you're
well-known within your audience you can
utilize a logo you can emphasize the
brand or the channel with a recognizable
logo so you'll see a lot of television
shows a lot of production agencies or a
lot of channels that are very well-known
their thumbnail focuses on the logo
rather than the content it'll use an
image that supports it but they don't
put a title in there like you saw in the
previous example now the third example
is the meme example and that's where
they will make the thumbnail look like a
meme by making it look like a meme they
focus on an image and then heavy
sans-serif fonts to make it look like an
average meme that is sent around by
people or posted it's to get your
attention it's to again create
excitement or create using the title to
get your attention and communicate what
the video is about as you can see these
both you know they're using very
strong titles in the thumbnail to get
your attention next is what I call the
Photoshop style and this is where the
thumbnail is just heavily photoshopped
it focuses on faces and very bold
graphics very colourful graphics and
photoshopped effects in order to get
your attention they try to communicate
the content through imagery quotes
titles and so but they're relying on
Photoshop to create the video thumbnail
again as you can see this does trend
towards a specific type of information
so it may not be the best for everyone
again this is going to be something that
you have to match to your business and
your personality again
this is uh this is one that I've just
noticed and I named it I call it the
white as you can see everyone's face
their mouth is open and their eyes are
wide open as if they are saying what and
this is to get your attention I have
noticed so much of this especially with
the clickbait title it's it they
sometimes use Photoshop effects but it
is meant to convey excitement and it's
one thing that I have noticed through so
many channels even YouTube creators who
have been there over the years they have
seen their click-through rates go up
when they post pictures like this in the
thumbnail and it shows its excitements
it's wow it's I can't believe that and
that attracts the click for their
audience again I'm not gonna recommend
everyone do this it's knowing who your
audience is and what appeals to them and
that's the big question who is your
audience what is your category how will
you present your content I've given you
a couple of examples but it's up to you
figure out what works for you but it has
to appeal to your audience okay now
let's look at methods that we can
utilize to build engagement and
retention again the more people click in
your video and around your video and on
your channel
that increases your visibility it
increases the ranking algorithm showing
that your popularity now one of the
first thing is what are called video
cards video cards as you can see here on
the video it's related content
now here the related content are
playlists and so as you can see here
from this top gear video they are
showing in the upper right of the video
additional playlists that you can watch
now you can set that in your YouTube
studio when you're in your YouTube
studio you can get in and there is a
place there to add a card when you click
on that there are a number of things
that you can do you can add a card to
promote a video or a playlist that's
what we saw before is that the top gear
channel is promoting a playlist you can
promote another channel this is good if
you're Co promoting or doing a promotion
you can create a poll to take place
within the video great way of engaging
with people and then you can link to a
website now this is where you have to
connect your channel to your own domain
and verify ownership or approval of that
website in order to make that link then
you can add links into your video cards
these will show up especially if you're
doing a product demonstration or this is
for business where you're utilizing the
video for business then you can have the
link to a landing page show up in the
video if people click on that link
through the card it will contribute to
your popularity because they're engaging
and YouTube can see that link click
through the system now the next and very
related are end
screens you've seen this if you've
watched videos on YouTube that when you
get to the end of the video that there
are suggested videos other videos that
are there you can set them
you can also set when they show up
towards the end of the video this is a
great way to promote additional content
in you
channel because if people click on those
it shows that they're engaged that they
watched the video the whole way through
and now they're clicking on more content
again we go back to our studio and we
add cards or we add end screens now
there's a couple of elements there that
you can add but end screens are the best
that people engage with and you can
choose from a couple of different
methods here you can choose your most
recent video that you've uploaded as one
option you can also allow the YouTube
algorithm to determine which of your
videos they might be more likely to
click on that's what it means best for
viewer that means you're putting it into
YouTube's hands to figure out what they
might like based on their past behavior
or based on what this viewer has watched
and so it's a great way to promote your
own content and keep people engaged your
analytics this is one of the things you
really want to look at and that is
audience retention and you from here
this is a very short video but it has an
83 percent duration and what that means
is that 80% of the audience is engaged
nearly the entire time of the video and
so it only drops off at the end but
still it retains the majority of the
audience for the majority of the video
and that is one of the primary metrics
that you want to watch on the other side
here we'll look at audience retention
now the video itself is 3 minutes and 16
seconds however the average view
duration is a minute 45 that means that
you are losing the majority of viewers
at the minute 45 mark and only about 53%
of the video is is being viewed and so
that tells you that you're losing
retention the goal is to keep the vast
majority of people watching as long as
possible so
you want to look at that 50% mark of
where am I losing 50% of my audience and
how can I gain them back
fortunately YouTube studio has added
some editing functions so you can go in
and edit videos that you've already
uploaded to try and optimize them maybe
find out where people are dropping off
and edit that out in order to keep
action moving but if you see a trend
like this where right from the beginning
people are dropping out that tells you a
little something about the video that it
may not be answering people's questions
and it's probably not engaging them so
we need to fix that trend alright we're
getting towards the end here what we've
covered
utilizing keywords going back to your
keyword research and finding what people
want the words they use and implementing
those keywords into your content
planning optimizing the videos through
the title and description tags as well
as creating playlists seeing the
popularity metrics and how YouTube look
it's those and how you can optimize
those but most importantly how to get
the click that's one of the primary
things that you need to do is get it in
the click getting people to your video
in your channel and then the important
analytics that gives you the feedback
how you can take action to improve your
videos let's move on to our third poll
Stewart I'll handle that over to you
before we go to our Q&A section
thank you Matt now that we've looked at
how to leverage SEO for your video
content we'd like to survey you about
the digital marketing skills you would
most like to add your repertoire use as
many as apply to you and surprisingly
SEO takes an early lead
I'll leave the poll open for about
another minute everybody gets a chance
to answer it's kind of a broad
distribution you'll see that when I
shared the little more time as I said
it's not a surprise that most people
webinar today would like to learn about
SEO I see that there's a broad interest
across almost all the other categories
as well with that on to question answer
and we
have some questions here from the
audience one that is can you suggest
free tools for video creation I know
that Apple operating system has some
built-in programs for video editing I'm
not really I don't know I don't use a
lot of free ones so the ones you you
know that there are some good video
editors out there that don't cost a lot
there's a number of things
there's a lot of creators that they can
edit right they're on their phones they
can find apps to edit from there it
doesn't take a lot to do those types of
things if you you know talk to anyone
who's in video creation and they could
probably recommend a few things that
they use I just use just some basic
video editing software that I've kind of
had for years in doing that and and
usually that just seems to work well
enough but then also YouTube itself
offers some editing tools now they
didn't use to but they've just enabled
that if you want to say a couple of
months ago related question how much
time do you usually spend when editing
videos for YouTube that's a good
question I talked to a lot of creators
and they estimate that for about a
five-minute video about two to three
hours of editing it's a significant
investment and so even you know some
creators are doing twenty to thirty
minute videos that is a significant
amount of hours and so you know any
content creator on YouTube very quickly
will become an editor that's just part
of it and a lot of it - it depends on
your business who your audience is but
you've got to keep that engagement high
and so the videos got to keep moving
very quickly
I personally make short films and I can
attest to the fact that you need a lot
more footage and a lot more time
figuring out how to fit it all together
absolutely related to that what you come
in
the difference between writing a blog
and scripting for a video absolutely
writing a blog you know you're writing
for someone who is probably sitting at
their desk looking for information and
they're prepared to read an article and
unfortunately on video even though it's
an entertainment based medium they want
information faster and more visually and
so your language needs to be more active
it needs to be I would say it needs to
move faster on video than it does in an
article in an article you can take time
present and structure your content
whereas in a video you've got to keep
people engaged very quickly because if
the video isn't going anywhere if people
don't think that they're going to get
the answer to their question they're
going to click off a great example of
this is I was trying to troubleshoot my
printer and so I went to YouTube and
looked for a video on you know what's
wrong with my printer part of it was I I
can't print color I can you know black
and white just fine but it's not
printing color so I go search for some
videos well one of these videos is a 10
minute long video I'm not gonna watch
that another one was a five minute video
okay I'll click on that but after a
minute and a half they haven't even
started to address the content and so
I'm gonna go find you know it's it
really has to do what the urgency people
have and the problem they have if there
is an urgency to their keyword to their
need then they're going to have much
patience we have time for two more
questions so I'm going to the first one
is what's the most critical metric
people should watch for optimizing their
videos retention rate is big if you see
that your video is losing a lot of
people within you know if you have a
five-minute video and you're losing a
lot of people in those first two minutes
or the first minute that's a big problem
and so that will certainly count against
you again it has to do are you if you're
not answering people's questions if
you're not entertaining them YouTube is
a hard medium
and they stress popularity and
popularity is based on your ability to
engage people so that retention metric
is probably one of the biggest that I
look at in video and the final question
is for the people who are interested in
learning how to become a YouTube
marketer learning the skill of YouTube
marketing is a difficult skill to pick
up and where would they start where
would they start
I find you know the roundabout way is
knowing your audience define your
audience who is it that you are
presenting to get an image of your mind
and think about their situation where
are they what are they doing what do
they want to see and develop your
content around that and then look at the
feedback through the metrics
click-through rates comments that'll
that'll worsen let you know if you're on
the right path so many times I see
people try and create content but the
they're missing the audience and that
will result in low click-through rates
low engagement low retention and
possibly even the wrong keywords so
knowing your audience is the biggest
place to start and that I think a lot of
that comes from your knowledge of
keywords and and you can apply SEO
skills to the other types of things but
then it's a to me it's a faster-moving
medium than search engine optimization
because the feedbacks right there and it
takes a lot more elements to to build
that okay I suppose another good place
to start this taking courses from simple
learn from instructors like you you just
answer the question absolutely start
there's lots of information on simply
learn about SEO and you know and I think
there's even more content about video
you know marketing through video and so
definitely take advantage of that all
right well thank you I think that
concludes our questions and answers all
right thank you very much I really
appreciate it this has been fun are
there places that people can follow you
on social media or connect yes probably
my bet you know my website is site logic
comm SI te l OG I see
logic calm I you know rather than do a
blog I've got podcasts where I talk with
other marketers about marketing but then
also my LinkedIn channel is probably
where I'm most active and that is at
LinkedIn and I am Matt Bailey site logic
and I'd also encourage everybody to
connect with simply learn you can see on
your screen the handles and IDs for
Facebook Twitter and LinkedIn as well
and want to thank you all for joining us
today
concludes our webinar so I encourage you
all defense to end the webinar log off
and answer the survey and we hope to see
you at the next edition
[Music]